the world of esports
is full of some pretty strange things
whether it's an insane fan reaction or
a really awkward interview okay well
uh which one of the other players on the
other team would you say are you biggest
competition in this game
well you have lost three matches in a
row today we're going through our top 10
weirdest moments in esports whether it's
the
hilarious the bizarre or even the erotic
trust me you're not ready for that one
but before we get into that i just want
to remind you guys to subscribe to the
channel if you haven't done so already
and hit that notification bell it really
does help us here
and with that let's get into the top 10
weirdest moments
in esports
making esports broadcasts entertaining
is an important
job
there are people who made careers out of
spicing up interviews and death segments
for various events
but for our number 10 entry the ti6
panel that was made up almost
entirely of puppets is a creative
decision that leaves us
scratching our heads even today maybe
they should rub your head for good luck
no dude nobody's going to rub mine i'm
going to rob you no don't rub my hair
don't rub my head this is for our
alliance oh okay all right good luck
no no no no no we charlie you said
earlier on we weren't supposed to do
rubbing
okay that's slightly essential look we
get it they were channeling their best
muppets energy but
given that a lot of people out there see
dolls and puppets
as nightmare fuel having an entire panel
of them at dota 2's biggest event
seems like a questionable choice then
again maybe no one behind the scenes
ever saw chucky
[Music]
coming in at number nine now is north cs
goes goodbye message for one of their
former players
hereby
[Music]
once the youngest major winner in cs go
history
these days kirby is more notorious for
ditching astralis for north
and spending the next two and a half
years trying to reach the competitive
heights of his younger days
the event that has impacted my career
the most is probably
leaving australis unfortunately he
wasn't really seeing the results he
wanted and in may of 2020
he decided to take a break from
professional counter-strike to take care
of his health
hereby said he was experiencing
abdominal pain
breathing problems and chest cramps not
necessarily life-threatening stuff
but not exactly a good time either so
north's choice of stylizing the tribute
to kierby's eventual departure from the
team
as a literal funeral came off as a
little bit odd
we just did a whole video on pop off so
you should know that they can be pretty
hype
it's team liquid and that's what it
means to them
but for our number eight entry tager's
trophy ceremony at the dreamhack open in
2013
is anything but in fact the whole thing
is so
underwhelming it crosses over into
bizarre territory
the cork has broken in half do okay we
need a bottle opener
if anyone has a fork okay okay robert
olin the ceo of dreamhack is gonna put
his pink okay this is a bottle of liquid
[Applause]
hopefully someone got the poor guy a
proper drink later
coming in at number seven is olaf
meister's unfortunate experience with a
fan who wanted something a little
different than
usual as unsettling as it may sound for
some people
touching their favorite celebrity can be
a truly transcendent experience
and esports is no different big events
present
fans with a rare opportunity to get up
close and personal with the players they
worship maybe get an autograph or even a
friendly
handshake but not everyone is satisfied
with a high five given in passing
one person just really wanted olaf to
high five
a dildo yeah we wouldn't be surprised if
the whole incident
put olaf off of any kind of fan
interactions for a
long long time unfortunately for other
players though
it was simply too weird of a moment to
disappear quietly
do you still have the dildos uh
no we will just hammer them down back to
you guys
at number six on our list is the most
awkward interview
in esports history hi boy how is it that
you're able to play with so much
confidence
on the world stage
[Applause]
look esports interviews can get pretty
cringe at times
but this one just takes it to a whole
new level
when i boy was interviewed by sharks
during worlds 2017
it almost redefined what an awkward
interview looks like
[Applause]
while he did eventually answer the whole
interaction from that awkward
microphone grab to the far longer the
necessary
pauses makes this one very strange
interview coming in at number five
is proof that when you gotta go you
gotta go
you know when everything's on the line
and nature calls nature comes first
toilet issue are you serious
what are we calling it that samsung
galaxy's cuvee just couldn't hold it in
during the
final match between his team and skt
during the 2017
lck summer split while needing to use a
toilet is perfectly natural
doing it five minutes before the end of
an important match
seems rather poorly timed still weird as
it may be
the call of nature just cannot be denied
seems the toilet issue is fixed guys
thanks thankfully
thanks to uh plumber cuvee who went in
there and dealt with that toilet
who knew he was a man of so many talents
and if you thought
sweet relief would improve cuvees and
his team's chances of
winning those seem to have gone down the
drain along with uh
everything else at number four now we've
got a
spooky curse from shocks at worlds 2020
fnatic won the first two matches of the
quarterfinals against
top and sharks took the opportunity to
deliver an impassioned monologue about
how well fnatic
and the lec were doing and how poorly
top and the lpl were faring against them
but so far we haven't gotten lpl
domination
we haven't gotten the jackie love
highlight reels and we have gotten
rekkles
and hilasang the series however
entered in a first ever reverse sweep in
the history of worlds
after fnatic lost the next three games
an upset that some fans blamed
inexplicably on shox's speech which i
separate like jinx's comments from
kill yourself you jinx them comments
yeah obviously
and it also got paired with a lot of you
don't deserve your job comments as a
whole like
the whole like the last 10 years don't
mean [ __ ] because you did
like one bad thing shocks took the
vitriol as gracefully as she could
even throwing back to the whole caster's
curse thing later on in the tournament
fanatic or on the right path unless of
course you believe in jinxing them
through a monologue in that case
you're a doofus and i can't help you
our number three entry is by far the
weirdest moment to have ever happened at
the tournament on purpose
it's well whatever this guy is doing
gamer fans are
you ready
at counter pit league season 2 the
tournament organizers hired mourinho
matic as
mc and his approach to hyping the crowd
up was so
jarring so far outside of what you'd
expect to see at a major esports event
some viewers actually complained give me
some noise
you can even scream if you want and
put your hands in the air in this grand
final
for the best counter-pit
fighters in the world but despite what
anyone had to say
matic went on to host dota pit season 5
with an
equal amount of enthusiasm he was one
big big big big blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
say what you will but the man is a
legend
coming in at number two is the weirdest
most unbelievable piece of
fgc's law the ghost of marvel 2.
chris chris
g moments after chris g won marvel vs
capcom
3 at evo 2016 a random
shirtless man got onto the stage and
challenged the new champion to a match
that man was then promptly escorted out
but the bizarro
incident still haunts the minds of
fighting game fans the world over
including chris g himself uh
he said something along the lines of uh
i'm not done yet
or it's not over yet until until he i
play him
and and i forgot what i said i was like
i was like i think i said like nah man
like or
like i saw it taking our number one spot
is a tale of an unlikely friendship
taking an even more unlikely turn one
day
faker and tyler1 went out together to
grab a bite to eat
the rest well you have to see to believe
that's it you're done
it's time for your surgery are you ready
no but
i mean let me at least make it fast like
probably not hands up being together
booty out okay you're going to be so
assertive man
all right here is one
i'm so sorry the silver lining to this
peculiar act of gastronomic debauchery
at least tyler1 got to have his ass be
in front of his idol
and who wouldn't want that that was an
experience
but i'm glad i could do it with you
faker
as for the rest of us i think we can
agree we were all left wondering
what the hell we just watched all right
there you go guys that was our top 10
weirdest moments in esports were those
weird enough for you
can you think of any weirder ones out
there trust me
i can take it thanks for watching guys
and i'll see you all
in the next one all right fellas let's
share the showy sequence
all right i'm gonna toss it back to the
desk this is getting a little intense
down here at esl one clone take it away